clark county leaders are preparing to
take on covid health responsibilities
from the state they submitted a plan
today as they get ready to fully
reopen the community christian casares
live right near the strip with a look
at some of the new changes we could all
be seeing christian
well brian this is definitely a step
forward returning to normal according to
county leaders now listen to this
according to the changes 12 people
will now be able to sit at a table at a
restaurant and four people now at the
bar
also buffets can operate with station
supervision
and those temperature checks will be a
thing of the past
this is a very well thought out plan i
appreciate all the effort that went into
this i have some questions clark county
commissioners review word by word
the proposed health guidelines to be
submitted to the state for approval
a major change capacity 2021
capacity restrictions in clark county
may increase to no more than 80 percent
occupancy that occupancy level
today is at fifty percent another change
the social distance requirement which
would decrease from six
feet to three feet which applies to gyms
indoor malls and retail stores
at one point we feel comfortable open
enough
to to really large uh gatherings over 20
000
people i will say that
once we reach a 60 percent
fully moon eyes clark county's first
dose vaccination rate is 44 percent
the expectation is to reach 50 percent
before may 1st
nightclubs and day clubs can also reopen
including adult entertainment
but dancing is not allowed until the
county reaches the 60 percent
vaccination marker
youth sports tournaments can hold events
with 250 people or less
without submitting a preparedness and
safety plan
well the next step in this process is
for the plant to head over to the
governor's desk
for consideration and approval and if
that is the case
well we could see this plan being
implemented
on may 1st brian and christian do we
know if this will
impact our entertainers since so many of
the shows are slowly starting to come
back
well brian from what we know the
proposal according to the county is
asking for entertainers to be
vaccinated and if they are then they can
be at least
three feet from the guest otherwise they
have to take
a weekly negative cova test so many
changes but all that information is on
our website 8newsnow.com christian
casadas 8 news now
all right christian thank you and i